so i see this article in the new york
post school board director jen mason to
teach sexual pleasure class to
nine-year-olds what
what
think about a nine-year-old
why
why does a nine-year-old ty were you
gonna say some you pull that mic i was
just gonna say this same person also
owns a sex shop called the wink wink
boutique which is an all ages friendly
sex store yeah we'll get to that in a
second
let's read let's let's have a little
reading time shall we you know when you
used to line up and barnes and noble and
sit around and read let's read a
washington state school board director
who owns sex shop as tyler referenced
is making headlines after announcing
she'll teach such sex education classes
for children as young as nine
on topics such as sexual anatomy for
pleasure what and safer sex practices
for all kinds of sexual activities can
you tell me why a nine-year-old needs to
be learning about sex practices
listen
if a nine-year-old is having sex there's
a problem and that problem's probably
starting at home there's something going
on there there are conversations that
are going on there's something wrong
there
nine-year-olds should not be thinking
about sexual activity
they shouldn't and if they are there is
something wrong at home there's
something wrong culturally
there's a lot of this going on forcing
it like like making kids think that
they're supposed to be thinking about
sex at nine
disgusting
disgusting the class for 9 to 12 year
olds because there's two classes just to
clarify there's a class from 9 to 12 and
there's a class from 13 to 17.
the content is supposedly different the
class for 9 to 12 is an introduction to
topics related to relationships puberty
bodies and sexuality we focus on what
makes healthy versus unhealthy
friendships and romantic relationships
these are nine-year-olds what do they
know or need to know about romance
please please tell me
the science of how puberty works consent
and personal boundaries for
nine-year-olds
defining sex and discussing why people
may or may not choose to engage in
sexual activities
does this seem age appropriate now if
you told me this was a class for 17 year
olds i'd still have questions about like
okay well shouldn't some of these
conversations be having at home one
and is there parental consent involved i
would still have questions but you're
talking to me about having conversations
with with babies nine nine think of a
nine-year-old you know a nine-year-old
that's a niece or nephew a nine-year-old
that's your own child a nine-year-old
you've taught in a school think about
what nine sounds like
what nine looks like what how nine
interacts with another nine-year-old
does this seem appropriate to you
i taught kids for years i will remind
you again
years of teaching children in middle
school high school this is not
appropriate for a nine-year-old
and it makes that nine-year-old think
that they're supposed to be thinking
about all this stuff
and they're not
they're not guys they're not
tyler mentioned that this particular
person owns a sex shop
whatever you're an adult you want to own
a sex shop i don't care i've been in sex
shops before i grew up in new york city
okay
i've been in them
wink wink
i don't know i think the name could have
been more clever for a sex shop just
gonna say if you're gonna push the
boundary on a sex top name make it i'm
wink wink i don't even get it all right
described as a woman owned identity
inclusive sex shop that is sex positive
body positive and gender affirming
while the uncringe academy is advertised
as offering honest supportive and
inclusive sex education classes to help
young people of all genders and sexual
identities understand this part
important part of life okay whatever
you can't bring you're a sex shop owner
you can't take that
and now decide that you're gonna stick
it stick all of what you do related to
the sex shop in front of nine-year-olds
and somehow that's a parallel universe
where those two things should be
happening at the same time this is this
is these are different worlds people you
want to own and operate a sex shop for
adults fine kids shouldn't be in a sex
shop
it's not appropriate and kids shouldn't
be having these discussions
i'm curious if there was parental
consent i don't know oftentimes i hear
from parents though that will say
i'll get an email or i'll get a message
that'll say my kid
went through this at school there was
some sex education thing i never knew
about it i didn't sign off on it
some say maybe i would have signed off
on it but i still want to be asked and
some say well i would have had questions
about the content because you're a
parent and you're entitled to those
questions so
again
why can't like kids just be kids anymore
why are we robbing children of a
childhood
there is so much time
where you have to worry about dating
relationships sex and
it gets really complicated in life
really fast by the time you're you know
18 19 all this stuff just starts
happening and life gets complex
in the same way that children shouldn't
have to obsess about money and finances
because they're supposed to be children
why are we putting this
hypersexualization on them
why is there an expectation now that
nine-year-olds are sexual
we're making them sexual because we're
talking to them about this stuff that
they're not supposed to be let them play
outside
think about nine my gosh i don't know
what i was doing at nine skinning my
knees and playing some freeze tag
think about it and think about the why
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here